[Music]
Monday night people are already so
excited to see what you Frankie have up
your sleeves Jordanna Harry Styles yes
[Music]
how did you because I am obsessed with
that song I love that song so much and I
feel like it just was really powerful
for the premiere so he's doing great
he's so much fun and we were just having
a blast in rehearsal I can't wait to do
it now because it's been so long it's
been like three weeks that we've been
rehearsing so we're like okay we just
want to get it over with and and just
get it out there so we're excited he's
are gonna be a slower dance event safe
to assume yes it's definitely slower
it's actually a box truck so we can tell
you it's a Foxtrot so it's really smooth
and graceful and we're getting it I'm
like I'm surprised by his by his work
ethic and by his talent so I'm I'm
hoping for a good season so yeah watch
me through the rehearsals with him is he
a fast learner a slow learner does he
have a lot of questions so Frankie is
actually super shy at first but he's
really funny and goofy robot not
thorough a lot as we keep going he is
actually just so funny and he's really
outgoing and we've just been happy we've
been having such a blast he is a fast
learner and he really wants to do well
like he's kind of a perfectionist where
he wants everything to be really really
good and so that's great it's a perfect
you know equation to success so you a
fan of his growing up at all you know
what I actually never saw malcolm in the
middle' which i know everybody knows him
for that but I've seen agent Cody Banks
Andy Cody makes to see big fat liar so
I'm definitely a fan for sure I walked
in like our first meet and I was like oh
my gosh agent Cody Banks I'm so stoked I
was really happy you really started to
annoy me
you have any idea going into this he was
gonna be your partner and given II say
no we don't have any say they the
producers really like to surprise us so
they don't tell us anything until we
walk in the room unless like they think
that we don't really know them then they
won't then they'll tell us before but
otherwise it's just a big surprise
[Music]